[Music]
you are by far the most
excruciating difficult stubbornly
obnoxious woman i've ever met in my
entire
life i [ __ ] love you
oh he's so sensitive he's romantic
sweet right
well i mean yeah when he's not being an
emotional [ __ ] terrorist
i love the way you see the world
[Music]
mystery the unknown it's what supports
the tension of a relationship
you're angry no so what if factor
hurry
what if there's someone who loved them
better
give me your pain
[Music]
give me your sorrow
[Music]
tell me why it hurts
i will carry you you know what malcolm
i feel like once you know someone is
there for you and once you know they
love you
you never actually think of them again
it's until you're about to lose someone
that you finally pay attention
well what is it marie what do you want
really
you want to go there yes
you want control because you can't
imagine the reason i'm with you is
because i
love you everything that you've been
through
everything that's what made you you the
girl that i love the girl that i [ __ ]
with
[Music]
all i wanted tonight was thank you
malcolm that is it
you know that i'm thankful you know that
i made a mistake so why turn it into
something more
because about how you see this
relationship
[Music]
look at me i'm the last person standing
[Applause]
hold on to me for dear life
[Music]
you